[Music]
well in our morning rounds a new study
is casting doubt on the health benefits
of even light drinking researchers from
the Washington University School of
Medicine medicine in st. Louis found
consuming one to two drinks four or more
times a week increases the risk of
premature death by 20% the study looked
at data from more than 400,000 people
our doctor Tara Narula
is a cardiologist at Lenox Hill Hospital
part of more well oh good morning good
morning Nora so tell us what this study
found well there's been a long debate
about the benefits of alcohol are there
benefits is there a safe threshold in
fact in April there was a study that
came out that looked at over 700 studies
and said there is no safe level and so
here we have this study that really
looked at light to moderate drinking and
found exactly what you said that if you
drink one to two drinks four days or
more per week your mortality risk went
up they did in fact find a lower risk of
cardiovascular disease well there are
some benefit answer risk increased and
so when you weighed that it seemed like
the increased mortality was really
driven by the increased risk of cancer
what can I get for three days on these
kinds of as you as you mentioned there
are other studies people feel like you
know next week it's just gonna change
that put this study in context in terms
of its rigor in terms of you know why
this is different well it was a big
study and they did look at sort of light
to moderate drinking as opposed to just
drinkers versus abstainers so that's it
was a good study in that respect I don't
think it's gonna change the guidelines
yet but really it adds to this growing
body of evidence that suggests that you
know what we really need to pay
attention to the cancer risk and we
can't just say well it may be beneficial
for cardiovascular disease and and allow
people to just go ahead drinking so what
is the connection on cancer and alcohol
I think this is interesting and I don't
think a lot of people think about that
but it is a group 1 carcinogen it
increased the risk of breast cancer head
and neck cancer esophageal cancer colon
cancer liver cancer and the thinking is
that alcohol or its byproducts may
basically be damaging to DNA or not
allow our body to repair DNA as well may
increase estrogen levels that could
drive breast cancer for example may not
allow us to absorb certain new
treants that we need like folate and
other vitamins or may raise obesity risk
which we know is a risk for cancer so
there are underlying mechanisms that
make sense
now on the cardiovascular side we know
that alcohol increases HDL which is good
protective levels of cholesterol good
cholesterol it also can help with
inflammation because it has antioxidants
in some of the types of alcohol and in
addition we think that it may be
anti-clotting so again it's this risk
benefit ratio that we need to pay
attention to I don't think there's gonna
be one fit for everyone and that's what
the study authors really point out that
we need to take this more personalised
approach and ask people do you have a
strong family history of cancer do you
have a strong family history of heart
disease what's your personal history and
then make recommendations based on that
for someone with a cancer history it may
be abstain because we know that the risk
goes up from no drinking you know with
each drink for cancer however you have a
strong cardiovascular risk then maybe
it's okay to drink one to two drink this
is a less-is-more type of rule exactly
may I recommend Martinelli's sparkling
cider or smart Starbucks white hot
chocolate good Thank You Tara